oh yeah hi hi I'm Mike I've never really  actively whoever I thought to be pretty  cool you really really want to be a part  of your movie bright it's just a great  film and reminds me a lot of alienation  I love right if you guys think a sequel  I really hope that you can include unit  I can do some action could be joel  edgerton stand in feel part of the  creative process even I can play dead  Will Smith oh wow your honor honestly  she just work was Will Smith that would  make my life trying to get demons about  her making turn to what be eat your body  receipt just ceasing opponent so  properly unleashing the Ducks I what got  the mood on if you guys play Shadowrun  we could play together  you